sounds animations endless Content
notifications the social media features
we've come to love but growing evidence
shows a darker side to the persuasive
tricks used by the biggest platforms in
the world the rewards of social media
activate the dopamine reward systems of
the brain the fact that when things act
very quickly but also kind of wear off
quickly as well leads you to want to
repeat them and so that in itself can be
part of an addictive process at yellow
ball studios they harness the techniques
developed over years of studying
Internet users a human eye loves color
especially with red stay notifications
are always noticed at red because
designer Lizzie Aten says nothing is
done by accident when you're pulling
down on your Instagram and then just
shows a little loader and then it sort
of pushes it up so the actual physical
proof pulling down the actions and so
that you're in control that's the way
slot machines works they periodically
give you a bit of money some prizes so
that's what makes you keep on going and
going and going and it's not just a
platform's appearance the systems we
can't see have become increasingly
sophisticated so of course they look at
what you've liked and commented on in
the past and that they also look at a
whole range of other factors like dwell
time so how long you spend looking at a
particular piece of content in your feed
how long you're pausing for but now
after years of working to keep us hooked
the social media Giants are backtracking
Facebook Instagram and YouTube are all
rolling out new tools to help us monitor
and cut down on usage to get deep
insight on how much time you're spending
where Apple and Google 2 are bowing to
public concerns the changes come as the
Royal Society for Public Health is
urging people to quit the big five
social media platforms for a month I'm
definitely picking up my phone a lot and
just unlocking it for no reason and I
think that's the biggest habit that I've
noticed it's really like it's in my
system and I'm finding that really
to get out of three of the five social
networks being quit have responded to us
snapchat argued it's not a social
network at all it said it doesn't employ
design techniques to encourage
compulsive or addictive behavior
Facebook and Instagram said the
well-being of the community is a top
priority they too rejected the idea that
their apps are addictive Joe tidy Sky
News
[Music]